>> Emily: JUSSIE SMOLLETT IS
STILL REFUSING TO ADMIT HE
STAGED A HATE CRIME ATTACK AND
HIS BROTHER IS GOING EVEN
FURTHER, CLAIMING THE DISGRACED
ACTOR IS REALLY AN ASSAULT
VICTIM WHO HAS BEEN FALSELY
ACCUSED BY POLICE OF MAKING IT
UP.
HIS BROTHER SAYING "JUSSIE A
STRONGER FOLLOWING AN ATTACK
LIKE THIS THERE'S A NORMAL
AMOUNT OF TRAUMA EVERYONE WOULD
SUFFER.
SOME OF MY SIBLINGS AS WELL AS
JUSSIE'S PARTNER AND CLOSEST
FRIENDS."
WHAT STRUCK ME ABOUT THIS IN
ADDITION TO THE LUDICROUS ASPECT
WAS THE FACT THAT IF THEY'RE
TRYING TO START A PAPER TRAIL OF
THERE BEING A PHYSICAL
MANIFESTATION OF DAMAGES IF THEY
ARE LAYING THE GROUNDWORK FOR A
LAWSUIT BY JUSSIE SMOLLETT
AGAINST THE CITY OF CHICAGO, I
JUST HOPE THEY ARE NOT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, GREG?
>> Greg: EVEN HAVE TO HAVE A
TREMENDOUS NUMBER OF PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THIS FRAME UP, LIKE
10,000 PEOPLE.
AS SOMEONE WHO DOES EXPERIENCE
NIGHT TERRORS, I EXPERIENCE THEM
WITHOUT EVER PERPETRATING A
MASSIVE HOAX WHICH EMBARRASSES
YOUR FAMILY, YOUR COWORKERS,
PEOPLE WHO DEFENDED YOU.
I CAN SAY GO SCREW YOURSELF.
HE RAN UP HIS VICTIM DEBT CARD.
EVERYONE HAS A VICTIM DEBT CARD.
HE WANTS MORE.
HE WANTS TO GET AN EXTENSION.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING ANY MORE FROM
ME.
BY THE WAY, NIGHT TERRORS, THEY
ARE BAD.
I HAVE HAD THEM.
>> Emily: WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A NIGHT
TERROR AND ARE NORMAL NIGHTMARE?
>> Greg: SLEEP PARALYSIS.
YOU FEEL LIKE YOU'RE AWAKE.
>> Jesse: I AM GOING TO SEE
YOUR "16 CANDLES" ANALOGY AND
RAISE YOU "WEDDING CRASHERS."
THE FREAKY SON TODD, MEMBER THE
WEIRDO?
IT DOESN'T MAKE PEOPLE FEEL BAD
FOR YOU.
IT MAKES PEOPLE LAUGH AT YOU.
NIGHT TERRORS IS WHEN YOU COME
HOME FROM IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN.
>> Dana: THANK YOU.
>> Jesse: I'M NOT GOING TO
MAKE A REQUEST TO MAKE AN
ANALOGY.
SMOLLETT IS THE MEDIA.
THEY BOTH PERPETUATED A HOAX.
THEY BOTH GOT CAUGHT AND INSTEAD
OF BEING CONTRITE, THEY ARE
DOUBLING DOWN ON THE HOAX.
THEY NEED TO LAY LOW, STOP
HAVING THEIR TEAM RIGHT BEDS AND
WAIT UNTIL IT BLOWS OVER.
>> Emily: ISN'T THIS THE
BROTHER JUSSIE SMOLLETT
PRETENDED TO BE WHEN HE WAS
PULLED OVER?
>> Dana: THANK YOU, EXACTLY.
AND KIM FOXX, SHE'S THE ONE WHO
SAID IN THE TEXT MESSAGE THAT
WAS REVEALED LAST WEEK THAT HE
IS A LIAR.
SHE SAYS THAT HE LIED TO THE
COPS.
I WOULD SAY TO THE BROTHER, NEXT
TIME YOU THINK YOUR BROTHER IS
HAVING A NIGHT TERROR AND YOU
ARE WITNESSING IT, HE IS AN
ACTOR.
>> Emily: TOTALLY.
JUAN, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Juan: IT'S NATURAL FOR HER
BROTHER TO STAND UP FOR ANOTHER
BROTHER.
IT'S HIS BROTHER AND HE FELT HE
SHOULD STAND UP AND SAY YOU KNOW
IT, GIVE MY BROTHER THE BENEFIT
OF THE DOUBT.
>> Emily: DO YOU THINK HE
BELIEVES THAT YOUR DO YOU THINK
HE'S JUST STANDING UP FOR HIM?
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW BECAUSE
I'M NOT IN HIS HEAD BUT I THINK
JUSSIE SMOLLETT CONTINUES TO SAY
THAT IT HAPPENED AS HE SAYS.
OBVIOUSLY THE CHICAGO POLICE
DON'T FEEL THAT WAY.
EVEN CHARLES BARKLEY DOESN'T SEE
IT THAT WAY.
>> Dana: EVEN KIM FOXX.
>> Juan: I'M SAYING JUSSIE
SMOLLETT HASN'T CHANGED.
THE POLICE, PROSECUTION.
HE'S NOT FACING CHARGES.
AT SOME POINT YOU'VE GOT TO
THINK WHY IS THE SYSTEM, WHY IS
THE GOVERNMENT CONTINUING TO
PURSUE A MAN WHO REALLY HAS BEEN
CHARGED WITH NOTHING?
THEY HAVE THEIR INVESTIGATION,